okay so you get it so debut novelist he
there he goes he's read this book well
done people
review it very nicely very it sells lots
okay
other authors are now going okay then
steven spielberg buys it i mean not at
the book he bought the rights
yes yeah he did yeah yeah if he bought
the book that's 799 in my pocket
but he bought the right yes so he's got
the rights and that you know i i
genuinely thought and
so you'll know what i'm talking about i
thought the world doesn't need another
tv presenter writing a novel right it's
not the kind of
thing yeah why would you do that so i
just thought
i want to make sure that this is okay as
an actual book and funnily enough you
were super helpful because as i was
going in the fact that your books
were genuinely brilliant people were
already they kind of thought oh no look
it's possible to be on tv
and be an author as well so generally
it's possible to do it more successfully
i now discover it i thought mine had
done well
no [ __ ] i will i will point out that
every week i get an email from the irish
publisher saying great news you're
number two in ireland again
who's number one oh graham still great
every week
every single week nobody did come on
steven spielberg
i was thinking i i you know i don't what
if this isn't any good
is honestly what i was thinking i think
so i wrote it in secret i didn't tell
anyone i was writing it because
no one you know needs a friend writing a
novel uh so i thought what if it's
anything the fact that spielberg read it
and came in and just said i love this
story i love these characters and he
bought and he didn't know
steven spielberg doesn't watch pointless
celebrities
he doesn't know who i am so he just
liked the story and that gave me a huge
amount of confidence and uh
and obviously i i played hard to get for
about like nine seconds
i would say and then yeah he's steven
spielberg isn't he well continued
success with the thursday murder club
richard osmond everybody
you